for
Francis
[Music]
yes for
work
m
we actually have a scene in Paris in the
film so there's a lot of Beautiful
Moments there's almost This Love Letter
to to Paris and to France in the movie
we actually use some of the old
buildings from Ratatouille and we
redress them for cars so we have a big
moment in France
that story that was a great story
because um we my wife Nancy and I've
been and I we have five Sons we've been
married um we've been married 23 years
and we love Paris we love going to Paris
it's very romantic and we were um you
know following directions to a friend's
house he's an animator and and we in his
directions took us across the Ponte Arts
Bridge which is that beautiful walking
bridge right there and on his directions
it said to to go to the bridge walk
across halfway
stop kiss and continue walking that was
in his directions and we thought oh this
is great and we did it and it was like
oh yeah he knows what he's talking about
and so that spot has become my wife and
my favorite spot in the world and we
will always whenever we go to Paris
we'll always take a moment to walk
across Pon bridge in k
my worst video game experience um let me
think um I got addicted to a arcade game
called digdug and I would play and my
arm would get so tense it was a joystick
kind right and my arm would get so tense
I I actually kind of got sort of
tendonitis you know and it was like um
and so I I um we were playing softball I
was on a softball team at the time and I
remember you know being so addicted to
the video game that I I I I threw a
softball once and it just my arm just
hurt so badly I couldn't play I couldn't
play softball I had to kind of like let
the arm rest and so I
said no more video games that's it cold
turkey I quit you know and it was hard
because I was so addicted to that game
my sons my five
Sons they they live to play video games
they love them all we we have we have a
we love video games at the last at our
house and stuff so
[Music]